okay so uh what is better than good
graphs
there are graphs that also hide the
information of the underlying data
so a little about myself uh my name is
gaatha and i'm doing my doctoral degree
in advanced data mining and my
specialization is in privacy so i have
some experience in the i.t domain and i
worked in many fields like
telecommunication finance and mobile
application development
so feel free to reach out and connect on
linkedin and twitter
i also write on medium so you can read
my work over there as well
so let's get started with a little bit
of
privacy needs first
so if a service provider or a product
designer says that they cannot consider
user privacy as one of the requirements
then they are actually breaking law
because their eu gdpr is one law that
has been a game changer it has changed
the whole
way that the world viewed privacy
requirements
apart from that there are many country
specific bills and acts that actually
take care of user data there is
something called common law duty of
confidentiality that is very specific to
uk
uh and also it is very specific to
healthcare domain so if a patient's data
is being shared by a healthcare worker
it mandates that the patient should know
how and who is also going to access
their data
and
data is very important if we stop the
access or if we put too much
regulations on it it would hinder
research and it would hinder development
of cutting-edge technology
so we have something called trusted
research environments
these are uh we can say closed
environments uh that control the access
to data and they have they are sometimes
maintained by third parties
so we have multiple layers of safety
guidelines and procedures in place
and there is a concept of safe input
where the data that is being given to
researchers and analysts it is checked
if it has been de-identified to make
sure that no individual's identity is
ever revealed and there's also concept
of a safe output so that whatever
results that an analyst might derive
from the safe data they do not cause any
data breach
so uh okay i have talked about myself
and okay this we can skip on this uh
this i talked about trusted research
environment
and uh okay this is like the pretty
pictures i had made i'm sorry i started
sharing so uh these are the five
stakeholders that are part of previously
a data privacy ecosystem i have talked
about data owner second is the data
subject so when you think of our
database uh
a data subject is that one entry in the
database that one record that who is
identified by a sensitive information
that we need to hide and some
quasi-identifiers like there's it for
the ethnicity
the other information that can help in
identifying that person
so you could be a data subject if you
have ever taken part in any survey or if
you're using certain app or any platform
where you check that okay i agree to
terms and conditions
and this is how someone is now recording
your data
the third stakeholder is the data
custodian uh this again is a separate
party from the owner the owner has
provided a custodian with authorized
access to the data
uh where does uh the custodian's role
the income significance is that uh if
you go down a few years you would
remember cambridge analytica scandal so
cambridge analytica was a custodian who
had my facebook users data
to sway the 2016 us presidential
election
so apart from enforcing their own
privacy guidelines they also need to
follow certain assets
the whole stakeholder is an attacker
so when a tackle need not necessarily be
a hardware setting and some data or
carrying out attacks it could also be a
white hard hacker or a researcher who
wants to ensure that no further breaches
happen and that your system is secure in
fact uh an attacker could also be a
noisy colleague or a noisy neighbor who
might want to know your salary from
certain reports or some data that has
been shared by a department
the first stakeholder who's very
important is the data consumer and most
of us have been that uh if we see a
report about uh vaccine vaccination or
dissemination reports we have been a
consumer we have seen all those
so how is it consuming important when
you talk about the pregnancy and the
visualization scenario they are
consuming the information that they're
presenting to them
okay so finally we come to graphs
thus they were the most enjoyable part
of maths classes and scoring i'm sure
most of you would ugly
they give a meaning to the numbers we
might have tables of data we might have
multiple images and text
but graphs tell you about the underlying
relationships that certain attributes
can have among themselves
and the trends that the data follows
it gives you clarity of presentation and
if you're trying to tell a story or if
you're trying to sway some decisions you
want to persuade someone you would use
graphs but oh look at this this trend
promises that we would have better sales
in future so this is how graphs are a
very important tool in data science
so let's play a game of visual hide and
seek
in a hypothetical world
i made a new friend whose name is alice
and i don't know much about her but i
can figure out that she is in her
mid-20s
and somehow she mentioned to me that she
was part of a certain study at the
hospital
and she was probably the youngest hunger
this is all i know
and the hospital had this data with them
and it had the names of people their
ages
it's uh what were their glucose levels
and if they were diabetic for numb
so they decided to publish a report
about the study
and what they did was they simply moved
the age to a certain range they did not
publish the exact number they made it
into a range and they did not publish
anything else not means not glucose
level nothing just people who have
diabetes in certain age ranges and their
numbers
what could be the problem there
shouldn't be any problem right
there was a problem
so i accessed that report and i knew
that alice was probably the youngest
over there
and while i did not know that alice was
directed now i know it
so the information that was supposed to
be hidden by the hospital is now out in
the open and i unintentionally got to
know about it
now it could become even more critical
if the information was not about her
diabetic status but her salary or her
buying behavior
or her genetic profile
so we can see that graphs are a
previously hazal it is a big weakness
but as dr eva would say our weaknesses
can also be a strength
so we get stronger as we get weaker
early cryptic message
so what does it mean it means that
graphs have something inherent that can
help in hiding the information that we
are trying to show from the available
data first of all uh the incurrent laws
can be caused by uh how we are reducing
the dimensions that we are plotting on
the graphs so we have univariate plots
like in this histogram we had only shown
one attribute the age and its count so
it is a united graph
then we have multivariate plots like
scatters and contours one in which we
consider more than one attribute and we
plot the trends according to them
so uh what we aim to do is we need to
introduce uncertainty through
visualization
and these two uncertainties are two
types the one is encoding uncertainty
which is about how truly the graph is
showing the intended information
so this is the producer side concept
and the other is the defaulting
uncertainty which is how understandable
is your graph to the user even after you
have introduced some uncertainty to it
so this is the consumer side concept
so when we talk about privacy preserving
visualization let's first focus on three
main questions
which we'll take now one by one
first is what are we aiming at we are
aiming at this fine balance between the
utility and the privacy of graphs that
we plot
and it is more difficult now because
there is no certain metric that says
that okay we have achieved x level of
utility for my level of privacy
so no fine metric for that while utility
in itself and in privacy in itself they
can be measured through certain metrics
when we talk about privacy there are
metrics like entropy and nature
information
so uh these are used we have the data
that needs to be protected the original
data set
and you have the data set that you would
be publishing either through query
results or if you have anonymized some
of the fields or you're showing graphs
so and a person can deduct some numbers
so we have original data and the
published data so entropy measures how
much uncertainty you have put in the
data between these two data sets
and mutual information measures how much
is uh how much mutual information exists
between the original data and the of
data so this is how we are measuring
privacy in itself
similarly utility of visual structures
there is something called clustering
quality or however the patents have been
preserved or you can present your graphs
to human subjects and show them okay how
well do you understand the proper data
but again no fine metric to measure the
balance between them it is still a topic
of research that is going on so what we
need to do now
is to move from data space uncertainty
to visual uncertainty
and it consists of both the encoding as
well as decoding uncertainty
and why is it important to study the
social visual uncertainty is because
designers should be able to measure
that up what attribute or how we are
able to
hide information through visual elements
take that output as feedback to the
system
and develop even more robust plots
so what are some major concerns before
we start with privacy preserving visual
visualizations the visuals must protect
against two disclosures
first is the identity disclosure that is
who is the particular individual if we
are plotting some database
if uh we should make sure that we are
not disclosing the identity of one
single record in that database
and the other is attribute disclosure
which is uh we should be able to hide
the sensitive information
or the cosy
this code or the job title or the
ethnicity of a particular person in the
data
an attribute disclosure can further be
used to implement an identity disclosure
and yes visual and visualization systems
are also subject to attacks
so imagine that you have uh
floated a website and it has a very
interactive system that you can access
to plot graphs of the data that you are
hiding in your database
uh suppose
you can check for count of the employees
in a certain department and minimum
salaries maximum salaries their plots
average salaries or salaries which are
below the average of a particular
department
so a person who is um aiming to attack
your system who wants to extract
information they have the computation
power we can assume that and we can
assume that they have a lot of time on
their hands so they would continue to
run queries they might try 50 queries
and then use your plots to zero down on
one person that they want to target
so this is how your visualization
systems are prone to attacks
and nexus can be attacked can you
predict attack scenarios so
visualization can also be used to check
how vulnerable your plots are how
vulnerable your data presentation is
so what are some common methods to
develop visualizations that preserve the
privacy of the underlying data
the first is the hiding of the data
so it is one of the most common method
that's available in the research
literature
and i'll be handling three types of data
in this
so first of all let's talk about
temporal data or time series
so yeah what happens is uh we use key
anonymization or l diversity or any of
the inherent anonymization techniques
that are carried out on data
and then we visualize
that perturbed or anonymized data
so in this example you can see two
graphs the left one and
it has
details of teachers and students they
have been anonymized and a teacher one
teacher they don't have any names
and where they were present at certain
time intervals
now t0 t1 t2 t3 they could be morning
afternoon evening and night
and it is their pregnant how their time
was spent
at different places
and then we have another graph where we
have done away with the identity of
people
we have simply generalized all the
students into one umbrella the blue line
and the teachers into another one the
orange line
so which one do you think will be more
private among these two visuals
the chat is not open but
you can think about it
and it's obviously the right one because
now we cannot tell where teacher 2 was
at time t1
or where does student force spend his
time at the end of the day or when he
goes to gym
but if we want to see what is the
division of how people spend time during
certain time or certain periods of day
if the bar is being used more in the
evening or in the morning that is being
pretty well shown from the right hand
side graph
now we come down to the spatial data uh
it is very important because uh we use
these applications for navigation and
perfect links so we see that our
activities they are shown on very nice
nice plot nice maps sorry so we have
these maps and we see our activities
okay like this is so nice to see
but we really need to hide our data of
where we were because uh breach of
location data can have a very
major implications on a security
so there are many ways to hide the
spatial data we can suppress the
coordinates and i noticed on this
witness app strava earlier their maps
used to have many landmarks on it it was
very easy to see where i had gone or
where i lived based on the landmarks
that were there
so with growing privacy needs what they
did was they started to suppress the
landmarks that were present on the map
image
so now uh the route is there the roads
are there but very few landmark names so
that is taking care of my privacy when
the data is published for viewing by
other runners on strava
let's take another example
we have these three maps the same map it
is the activity of a student who moved
around university of california
and his locations they decide okay means
cluster then we'll hide them so three
strategies were used the first strategy
was let's limit the clusters 200 meter
radius
max is 100 meters 75 anything lying
between that we put it in one cluster
and number of uh connected points should
only be two
so we see in a we have many clusters a
lot of them
then b uh let's go to b uh what we did
was we merged the original clusters
and we said okay let's at least make it
to three points that are common between
the clusters then we will make mini
clusters into a bigger cluster
and the third strategy is when we
increase the maximum radius to 600
meters from 100 meters
so as you can see there are different
granularities we have done for
clustering the coordinates on the map
while a has many cluster
many many
spreader clusters
it is not doing anything to hide his
privacy
and when we come to b
again the cluster is too big it is of no
increase
in this case we are losing out on by
utility because if i just do see the
clusters and not the points it would be
a very big area it wouldn't be any use
to
predict where the student spends this
time
in casey we can still have some clusters
and still say that okay the middle part
if it is the central uh area of the
campus we can say okay the major part of
the student's day spent in the center of
the campus
then if on right side there is some park
maybe goes in and spends a good amount
of time there
on left if there is a bar that maybe he
goes there regularly as well and a
smaller cluster maybe his dom students
hardly sleep so maybe the right hand
side small cluster is the dom and that's
where his friends is sleeping ours
so in this we can see that the
clustering technique number c
is the best technique among the three
now we come to non-spatial data
so sometimes we need not show the
individual data to see the behavior of
the whole demography
in this case when you talk about episode
episodic traces it means what is the
behavior of a demography or a person for
certain activities
in this example twitter messages for 302
days they were analyzed to see
which is the preferred place from where
people prefer to tweet
it could be from home it could be from
mall it could be from place of transport
uh while you're traveling you obviously
open up all the apps and catch up on
people and media
this parking and the gym
so in this graph you can see there is no
person's identity here there is no
chance that i can find a single person
or to just graph but i can see
that the information that i want to see
is that okay home shopping and some in
some location that would not be asserted
to certain label
these three places are the ones from
where people prefer to tweet
and then you can see there are other
places as well but there is no exposure
of coordinates there is no exposure of
any other causal data for any person
now we come to the second common method
of
plotting privacy protection of through
visualization
so in non-spatial data this was the data
set uh for diabetes patients that's in
uci repository
so again we carried out key
anonymization on the data center so
canonization is one of the most common
method to support suppress the
information in a record
when we surprised by saying k
anonymization k is a very
properly calculated value when we say it
is key anonymous by 2 it means that one
person is his record is pretty similar
to one another person
so k minus one persons
in third case if we see that k is equal
to three
we have made a record identical to two
other records
and in fourth case if we have said we
have done key anonymization of degree
four then it means that a person's
record
is identical to three other records
so we have caused a lot of officiation
in this parallel plot in first one you
can see the first one is uh the number
of times the patient was pregnant
second is blood pressure
third is if insulin was given to them or
not and their bmi their age and their
classmates they were diabetic or not
so if we were to find that okay someone
who had never been pregnant
and uh if they had been diabetic we can
trace their uh properties through
certain attributes what was their blood
pressure it was just pretty clear out
here in the first graph what were their
properties
so uh in b we anonymize them by k equal
to two
still we can discern that a person who
had not been pregnant and was diabetic
what could be the properties
whether their bmi uh majority of the bmi
lied in heavy range or not we can see
majority of it was in healthy range
what were their ages whether they were
young
[Music]
so we can see that okay
they the majority of age group is under
healthy injustice not too many more
people
the same with the blood pressure
so even now we can gather some
information from this obfuscated graph
if we come to case 3 where the
anonymization has been of level 3
now there is some confusion in the graph
now the utility is being compromised a
bit
it is very difficult to tell the number
of times a certain person was pregnant
and what was their bmi what was their
blood pressure and how it mapped to
their diabetic students
and let's add much more confusion and do
gain anonymization of level 4. so
this graph is extremely private and it
is very less useful
so the calculation of these parameters
that are used for anonymization or
suppression or noise addition they need
to be done very carefully
and then may be plotted and seen that
how well you are showing your later
when we talked about the common method
the second was masking the underlying
data
so how masking is different from hiding
in hiding we have carried out operations
on the data
while masking uses the elements of a
plot when we think of a graph there are
lines
there are glyphs there are human figures
or there are cat faces and there are
pixel colors there are bubbles so these
are your visual elements by masking the
underlying data we mean that we use
these visual elements
to translate the underlying data
so the common methods definitely is
clustering like we had seen in spatial
data that we can make clusters around
data points and hide them under clusters
very well computed clusters
while our two clusters overlap
they hide the identity of a person
and clusters are split based on certain
attributes that you decide that okay
let's decide
let's write them over zip codes or let's
divide them over certain places from
where they are treated
so clusters in them in themselves
they're using colors and they're using
screen elements to mask the data
another very interesting concept is
pixel oriented visualization of pixel
binning which i'll be talking about
[Music]
so pixel binning is about using your
screen
as a screen and its area as a means to
achieve the privacy
when you think of a screen it is divided
into pixels you can imagine as a grid
with x and y it has x pixels that go
from left to right and by pixels that go
from bottom to top
so how do we use the pixels to hide the
information
we can
divide the screen into windows
with each window size being an attribute
i'll be taking an example in the next
slide so it becomes clearer
and we use pixel color as an attribute
value so an example could be a patient
record and if i want to show uh the
bed occupancy in a hospital by year a
month so pixel color could be the bed
occupancy for one day is two days three
days and i can use a color map so blue
would mean for one day a violet would
mean for two days sign would mean three
days and so on
and my screen width i can divide the
width and that is the x-axis of the
screen to here and height that is the
y-axis into month
so each pixel would become my bin where
i am putting in the information
i can also change the granularity of my
x and y axis of the screen to month or
week
this can be done through functions or
transform functions that we can use to
further hide information
so let's take an example of the finance
domain this time rather than going for
some people
so we have this uh
we are showing the stock prices that we
need over seven years
and this is the monthly trend so when
i'm seeing seven years
and each year has 12 months this is the
time series data that we have shown in a
screen space so your weight has been
divided into each year
and your y-axis that is the height of
the screen has been divided into months
so the 12 months of one year are when
you're going from bottom to top
and your each year is going from left to
right
and we have assigned colors to the stock
prices so dow jones you can see that
light color means a very good stock
price
and the darker the color it means a bad
stock price
so rather than plotting a time series
we have used the properties of the
screen and the pixels to show the time
series datum
the last one and very important
application of visualization is through
evaluation of risk
suppose you have a data set at hand so
some tools have been developed by
researchers
they can show that how much privacy
exposure is possible through your
visualizations
and they also show how you can achieve
better privacy preservation through
different different techniques you can
hide the data you can move it a level up
for instance if we talk about job title
it can be moved up to the department
and as we had seen in the case of
feature age it can be moved to a range
or a range could be split into smaller
ranges like a decade could be broken
into five years
so let's see this one example that was
developed by some researchers in 2017
so it had five stages in it
first of all they allowed a person to
load the data set and show exactly which
attribute they wanted to focus on
so if you see there is a lock on the
expense so the
user i would say the user is a person
who is trying to analyze how to achieve
how to analyze the risk the privacy
exposure risk so the user had marked a
lock on the expense which means that
expense is the sensitive information of
this data set
and we have the name of the person
the occupation
age gender so the person does not want
to change the expense
because it would be the output
and the attributes name occupation
gender and age they want to work on
those
so i'm sorry the name is the sensitive
information there
so the second part is it consists of
three steps so first of all uh the
system offers the user that how they
want to uh
split the
attributes so i have age i have
occupation of student teacher
others
so i can decide what attributes i want
to change their granularity whether i
want the age to be divided among decades
or five years for two years
the
it is a very fine trade-off between how
fine you want to go
from a discrete value
to a category
in the second one you can change the
order of the attributes so what they did
was they constructed a tree of
attributes
in this tree uh if you're splitting a
node then it should be towards the leaf
and not the root so if a person wants to
split the age more than the occupation
the occupation is fine with three
classes but eight should be split more
so the user can move age further down
the tree that i'll make the age into a
leaf and let it split more rather than
the occupation
and the third one is again how much
diversity do you want among the
attribute values how much do you want to
suppress them or how much do you want to
perturb them
so this is all written system that the
researchers have developed
now the next is uh it is a graph that
showed how much of utility had has been
preserved
from the previous step
so in this uh
the bubble chart they showed the
relationship between the categorical
variables
and the
line ones were for the continuous values
and the blue plots that you see in
number three
those are for the composite ones for
instance teachers who were females
so this is showing the perturbation that
would be caused for those aggregate
variables
or for students who were between the
ages of 10 to 20 or students who were
female
so this is how a person would see that
how the aggregated variables
and the continuous and the categorical
variables would be modified and the next
step would be addition of noise and
eventually what you would receive as the
output would be uh the plot of the data
that has changed in number four you can
see
there is the data chart that the changes
that we had wanted to preserve are also
available in the process data
when you see the darkest of the portion
of the grid it has been preserved from
the original to the process when you see
the lightest of the cell in the thread
that has also been preserved from the
data chart to the final chart
and eventually the user would have the
option to either
use this data as such with its
categories and its ranges or download
the data in the tabular form in which
the original data had existed so the age
again is a continuous variable it is not
a range
and the gender and the occupation also
they map to the original classes but
this time the person has tweaked the
utility and the privacy attributes of
the data that was contained in the
original one
what we have received is something that
has been changed by the user and a
certain noise has been added to it
so a recap of what we saw uh that how we
use visualization as privacy
preservation
there is a need to balance utility and
assert editing so we are talking about
graphs uh if we add too much of
uncertainty then we cannot get good
utility out of it
there is definitely a need to uh protect
against disclosures of a person's
identity and their attributes that can
be used to come back to them
uh there are some common methods to
achieve this first is hiding the data in
this we work on the data we check what
is its property if it's temporary if
it's patient of its non-spatial
we carry out the
most suitable
techniques on them
and then we plot them
then the second technique is masking the
data through visual elements so we use
the property of the screen and the
pixels to hide the data rather than
doing anything on the data
and third is how we use visualization to
evaluate any disclosure risk that a
certain dataset has
maybe tweak it if the system allows it
maybe add noise if the system allows it
and then use this modified data for
further analytics
i have listed down the papers that i had
referenced for this presentation
and this is from my side and please ask
questions
if i was not clear anyway yeah thank you
it was a lovely presentation
thank you everyone thank you